سلاح امريكي مرعب يورط الكيان الاسرائيلي
في الحرب الاوكرانيه وكيف توجه طلبا خطيرا
للالمان ينذر بحرب عالميه فما هو هذا
الطلب وهل تستجيب برلين اليابان تشعل فتيل
التوتر مع الدب الروسي مجددا واحفاد هتلر
يتحركون عسكريا فاين هي الوجه امريكا تضع
يدها في خساره الصين وبكين تتوعد بالرد
بقوه ولاول مره تركيه تدخل سوق العمالقه
وكوريا الجنوبيه تضع الملح في جراحكم
النوويه وساعه الصفر بين ايران وافغانستان
تدق ناقوسها والنتائج كارثيه
50 ليره دولار في مهد الري
الخسائر ولا غيرها هي التي تتصدر المشهد
الغربي والسبب حرب اوكرانيا هذه الحرب
التي عرفنا متى بدات لكن لا احد يعلم متى
تنتهي وبعد اكثر من 15 شهرا من الحرب ها
هو رئيس لجنه الماليه والضرائب في
البرلمان الاوكراني دانييل
تلقت اكثر من 50 مليار دولار كدعم خارجي
ذو بدء العمليه العسكريه الروسيه الخاصه
فعن اي مبالغ فلكيه نتحدث ومع كل تلك
الخسائر لا تزال اوكرانيا تمد يديها نحو
الغرب وهذه المره طلبت رسمي تزويدها
بصواريخ كروز بعيده المدى من طراز تاوروس
قادره على ضرب موسكو وذلك وفق صحيفه
فرانكفورتريل العامه الالمانيه ليعتبر
الروس ذلك بانه طلب خطير وحساس يندر بحرب
عالميه عند التدقيق قليلا فصواريخ تاورس
بعيده المدى ويمكن تثبيتها على مقاتله 16
التي تنتظر اوكرانيا استلامها من الغرب
لتصبح الاراضي الروسيه في مرمى اهداف
الاوكران فكيف سيرد الدب الروسي التحرشات
الغربيه بروسيا لا تنتهي حيث نقلت مصادر
اسرائيليه ان الامريكان قد يسلم اوكرانيا
20 مروحيه ضاربه من طراز اباتشي
الولايات المتحده من الكيان الاسرائيلي
وتعد هذه المروحيات سلاحا خطيرا قد يظهر
في اوكرانيا قريبا بانتظار الرد الروسي يا
ساده فيما اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيان
كندا تستكمل خلال الاسابيع المقبله تسليم
الاف من قطع الاسلحه الصغيره والذخيره
الحيه التي تبرعت بها لاوكرانيا اما
اليابان فوضعت نفسها مجددا على ق الدولي
غير الصديقه لموسكو وهذه المره اشعلت
طوكيو الى التوترات مجددا وذلك بعودتها
الى خط العقوبات حيث قالت وزاره الخارجيه
اليابانيه ان الحكومه تبنت حزمه عقوبات
جديده ضد روسيا شملت هذه المره ثمانا
وتم حظر التصدير الى ثمانين شركه ليعلن
وزير الخارجيه الروسي خلال استقباله
المنفذ الصيني
انه يرى عقبات جديه امام حل سلمي في
اوكرانيا مشيدا بالدور الايجابي لبكين ومن
انعدام الحل السلمي الى الحلول العسكريه
هنا قالت موسكو ان الدفاعاتها الجويه
اعترضت صاروخي كروز بعيدي المدى من طراز
كانت بريطانيا قدمتهما لاوكرانيا واعلنت
الدفاع الروسيه انها تصدت لصواريخ من طراز
هايمورس وهرم امريكيه واسقطت ايضا 19
طائره مسيره وقامت بتصفيه نحو 500 مسلح
على كافه المحاور خلال الساعات الماضيه
ومن اوكرانيا الى الاراضي الروسيه حيث
يحاول الاوكران قوات موسكو وذلك بسحب
الحرب الى العمق الروسي وهنا قالت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه ان قواتها احبطت محاوله
مجموعه تخريبيه اوكرانيه لاختراق خط
الجبهه في اتجاه مدينه الكسندر بينما اعلن
حاكم مقاطعه بسكوب الروسيه انه هجوما
بمسيارتين منظمتين استهدف محطه لتكرير
النفط في المقاطعه وقالت مصادر روسيه ان
قصف مدفعيا اوكرانيا استهدف منطقه
جهاز المخابرات الاوكرانيه بان بعض
البلدات منطقه
خارجه عن سيطره الكريم وذلك
[موسيقى]
الامريكيه وزير الخارجيه الاسبق انعكاس في
عيد ميلاده المئه بان تصاعد التوترات بين
الولايات المتحده والصين اقتربوا من ان
يتحول الى صراع حقيقي بين الطرفين مضيفا
انه بالنظر الى الاسلحه الحاليه لديهما
يمكن ان يهدد ذلك بتدمير الحضاره بحسب
هولس للجورنال لكن امريكا لا تلتفت
لتصريحات حيث اكدت سلطات الدفاع
التايوانيه وصول الشحنه الاولى لصواريخ
ستينجر من طراز
الى الجزيره قادمه من الولايات المتحده
لياتي الرد الصيني من وزاره الخارجيه التي
اعلنت ان بيع اسلحه امريكيه لتايوان خطوه
خاطئه وخطيره للغايه وان الصين سوف تحمي
بشده سيادتها الوطنيه وامن اراضيها هناك
ابحرت حامله طائرات صينيه عبر مضيق تايوان
في احدث تصعيد توترات العسكريه بشان
الجزيره بينما دخلت سفينه ابحاث صينيه
منطقه قريبه من حقول غاز تعد من ضمن
المناطق الاقتصاديه التابعه
فما الذي ينوي اصحاب العيون الضيقه فعله
بهذه التحركات
الاحداث والتطورات
نجحت كوريا الجنوبيه في اطلاق صاروخ نور
الفضائيه الذي اوصل ثمانيه اقمار صناعيه
الى مدار الارض اعلن رئيس وكاله الصناعه
الدفاعيه اسماعيل دمر عن تسليم 9 مدرعات
برمائيه محليه من طراز الزها للقوات
البحريه التركيه وذلك كجزء من مشروع تسليم
27 مدرعه برمائيه الى القوات البحريه
التركيه اغلقت السلطات الافغانيه معبر جسر
الحرير الحدودي في ولايه نيمروز مع ايران
بعد اشتباكات استمرت عده ساعات بين
الطرفين استخدمت فيها الاسلحه الخفيفه
والثقيله بحسب وكاله مهر الايرانيه 50
مليار دولار من الغرب لاوكرانيا لتكبيد
روسيا الخسائر لكن الخساره الحقيقيه يبدو
انها ليست سوى مليارات الغرب التي
ذهبت ولم تعود